we're in the homestretch we figured out
constraint on B in terms of M for that
line that's tangent to both the circle
and the hyperbola I want to make one
clarification here here in the last
video I took the principal root when I
took the square root and that's because
I want the y-intercept to be positive
remember when we look at this drawing
that I did in the first video over here
this y-intercept needs to be positive in
order for it to have a positive slope
and be tangent to both the circle and
the hyperbola in this way and so down
here so down here you definitely want to
take you definitely want to take the
principal root now with that said this
is the constraint from the hyperbola
this is the constraint from the circle
let's set them equal to each other and
solve for M and then we'll have our
slope of the line so let's set them
equal to each other so we have the
square root the square root of 9 m
squared minus 4 is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to negative 4 M
plus 4 times the square root of M
squared plus 1 so the first thing we can
do let's square both sides of this so we
get 9m squared minus 4 is equal to this
term over here squared so this is 16 M
squared and then plus 2 times the
product of these two terms so the
product is going to be negative 16 M so
it's going to be negative 32 M times the
square root of M squared plus 1 and then
plus Square this term 16 times M squared
plus 1 so let's try to simplify this a
little bit get maybe the radical on one
side of the equation and see if we can
simplify this and see if we can simplify
this even more so it's a good place to
start so let's see this is going to be
this is going to be this term right over
here is going to be a 16 M squared plus
16 so on the right hand side let me just
write it like this we have so we have 9m
squared minus 4
is equal to on the right hand side we
have 16 plus 16 we have 32 32 M squared
plus 16 minus 32 M times the square root
of M squared plus 1 and let's see we can
subtract we could subtract 9m squared
from both sides so we'll subtract 9m
squared from both sides and then we can
add 4 to both sides we can add 4 to both
sides and then we are left with actually
let me do it the other way because I
want to isolate this on the right hand
side let me do it the other way so let's
subtract 32 M squared from both sides
minus 32 M Squared from both sides 32 M
Squared from both oh yeah might as well
do this way so subtract 32 for M Squared
for both sides and then subtract 16 from
both sides subtract 16 from both sides
the left hand side 9 minus 32 is going
to be negative 23 because 23 plus 9 yep
is 2 so this is negative 23 M squared
minus 20 is equal to is equal to
negative 32 M times the square root of M
squared plus 1 now we can square both
sides of this equation it's not the
cleanest problem in the world but
hopefully if we haven't made any
mistakes we'll get someplace productive
actually let's multiply both sides
equation x times negative 1 just to make
it positive simplify things so that
becomes positive positive and positive
you square the left hand side of the
equation we get 23 squared let me write
it this way we get 23 M Squared squared
plus 2 times the products of this so
this would be 40 let me just write it 2
times 20 times 23 M squared plus 20
squared which is 400 is going to be
equal to 32 squared or I'll write it's
32 M squared times M squared plus
one and let's see what we can do over
here so this turns into this is just a
big tedious problem so I'll just write
this is 23 M squared squared plus so
this is going to be 40 this is 40 times
23 so 23 times 4 is 92 so it's gonna be
plus 920 M squared plus 9 actually let
me expand everything out here let me
just go straight to the number so 23
times 23 23 squared 3 times 3 is 9 3
times 2 is 6
69 put a 0 here 2 times 3 is 6 2 times 2
is 4 so you get a 9 6 plus 6 is 12
1 plus 4 is 5 so you have 529 529 m to
the fourth plus 40 times 23 4 times 20
is 80 4 times 23 is 92 so there's going
to be plus 920 M squared plus 400 is
equal to so we're gonna have 32 squared
let me figure out what 32 squared is 32
times 32 it seems like if you're taking
this exam you might have your month you
might as well have your multiplication
tables memorized to about 50 and I think
they do that on purpose so just you get
a sense I mean this isn't an exam where
the test takers expect everyone to get a
perfect the threshold I believe I think
the number one score in India is on the
order of 80% right which is pretty darn
amazing to be able to do roughly the
math section in about an hour
80% right it's pretty amazing but I
think to make the threshold of getting
into these highly selective colleges I
think you have to get around 40 or 50
percent correct of it you know forgive
me if I got that number wrong but I
think it's on that order so they need to
do that because you have two or three
hundred thousand people in India taking
it so you need to make sure that you
have a good spread of people so this is
what they do to spread people out so we
have 2 times 2 is 4 2 times 3 is 6 and
they put a 0 here 3 times 2 is 6 3 times
3 is 9 and for example if I if I was
preparing for the exam I might even go
ahead and
you know and you know me I hate to
memorize things but if you had to do
this type of problem in the order of
five on the order of five minutes you
might want to memorize these type of
things ahead of time you know the the
the y-intercept for a line that
intercepts the hyperbola y-intercept for
a line that intercepts a circle who
knows but anyway but in general I don't
think it's good to memorize in life
because when you're actually doing math
problems in your life what matters more
as you understand the underlying meaning
and you normally have plenty of time to
do it in your real life these exams are
kind of an artificial circumstance but
anyway 4 plus 0 is 4 6 plus 6 is 12 and
then you have so it's 10 24 is equal to
1024 that's the 32 M squared times M
squared plus 1 or another way this is
1024 1024 M to the fourth M the fourth
plus 1024 M M Squared and now we are in
the homestretch so let's subtract 529 m
to the fourth from both sides so minus
529 m to the four this is extremely
tedious minus 529 m to the fourth
frankly at this point in the problem
you're better off if you just want to do
it for speed just trying out the choices
they gave you and figure it out figuring
out which M's and B satisfy that but
anyway let's just let's just move four
on which M's which M's is satisfied that
probably be faster but let's just solve
it properly so minus 529 m to the fourth
plus and then we also want to subtract
920 M Squared so let's also subtract 920
M squared and so on this side were just
left
let's also subtract let's also subtract
a 400 just to make this a proper
quadratic and also going to put a 400
here so the whole left side simplifies
to 0 is equal to 1024 minus 529 let's
see 1024 minus 524 would have been 500
would have been 500 and so it's going to
be 5 less than that so it's going to be
495 and to the 4 did I do that right
1024 minus 524 would be 500 but I'm
subtracting 5 more than that so that is
going to be 4
95 and then 1024 - 9 20 seats 80
it'll be 80 plus 24 80 plus us so it's
going to be plus 100 and 4m squared -
400 - 400 is equal to zero so we have
just a straight-up quadratic equation
over here and you might not recognize it
but this is this is the same thing m to
the fourth is the same thing as M
Squared squared so let's just solve it
so we will get M Squared we're not
solving for x anymore we're gonna get M
Squared using the quadratic formula is
you could substitute X is equal to M
Squared and this will just become a
natural quadratic then M Squared is
equal to negative B negative 104 plus or
minus the square root more fun math for
us without a calculator
plus or minus square root of 104 squared
minus 4 times a which is 495 times C
which is negative 400 so that'll make
this a positive and you have Plus you
have a 400 right over here and then all
of that over 2 times 495 - times 495 is
what that's going to be 800 it's going
to be what's going to be 10 less than a
thousand so it's gonna be 990 990 so
let's try to see if we can evaluate this
actually I'll stop this problem here
I've already crossed the 10-minute
threshold in the next video we'll just
grind through this mathematics it's
really just arithmetic at this point and
figure out what M is going to be equal
to